foreign  [Music]  you think your wife can hear you no  white ball  Maybe I'm Wrong  I'm going to die  maybe not goodbye to you my trusted  friend  [Music]  a new day is Dawning  no ideas no wounds  New Management we've  since we  who is this  challenging to single combat with a  loose it's a way out  I don't sit at the table your family  does please pray for me  I was the black sheep  man has to look his best when it's time  to get married  or buried  I'm going to need a gun goodbye my  friend  [Music]  if you win  the table will honor its word  you'll have your freedom  under the old laws only one can survive  failure to meet at sunrise  for result in execution  Last Words Winston just have for another  [Music]  I want you to find your peace but the  good death only comes after a good life  [Music]  you and I left a good life behind a long  time ago my friend  let's go  [Music]  [Music]